nous sommes ici à saussan turquie à
quelques kilomètres à peine de l'île de
lesbos en grèce nous sommes ici en fait
sur une base de départ d'embarquement
pour les migrants on a croisé ici
plus d'une centaine de personnes tous
viennent d'afghanistan est des signes
qui ne trompent pas regardé par exemple
ici il ya un moteur hors bord qui
visiblement qui n'est pas en état très
probablement de très mauvaise qualité et
des pompes ici parce que les zodiac sont
à usage unique des bateaux gonflables
qui sont gonflés ici emmené ensuite vers
la mer pour partir
on les allèges ces bateaux-là de tout le
poids inutile
le but c'est de mettre le plus de monde
possible à bord de ces bateaux là au
détriment d'air de la sécurité et les
planchers de bois par exemple sont
systématiquement retirés pour enlever du
poids on trouve un peu partout sur les
plages des sacs à dos parce que les
passeurs en fait tu retires les sacs à
dos des gens pour soulager un peu les
bateaux et s'assurer de mettre plus de
gens à bord sur des embarcations de 9 m
ce qu'on nous dit c'est qu'il ya
quarante-quatre personnes qui montent et
c'est un flot constant et regarder si
les gens sont là en attente de partir je
vous parlais d'une centaine de personnes
ils sont arrivés ici pendant la nuit et
ils sont en train de camper pour
l'instant ils ne savent pas encore quand
ils vont partir les attendait sommes des
passeurs
ils ont pour certains d'entre eux des
vestes de sauvetage
la plupart d'entre eux ne savent pas du
tout nager ne savent pas sur quel genre
de bateau ils vont s'embarquer savent
pas dans quelles conditions ils vont
naviguer
il ya des femmes il ya des enfants il ya
des bébés tout ce qu'ils savent c'est
gens là c'est qu'en fait ils s'apprêtent
à s'embarquer pour ce qui est sans nul
doute la partie de loin la plus
dangereuse de leur long périple c'est
quand on vient sur cette plage où
partent les migrants sur la côte turque
que l'on comprend les dangers réels
auxquels ils s'exposent des bouées qui
ne sont en fait que des chambres à air
de voitures des effets personnels
abandonnés un peu partout par les gens
bousculé sans doute par les passeurs et
puis c'est au diable ces bateaux
pneumatiques qui leur servent
d'embarcations celui-ci déchiré crever
échouées sur la côte montre à quel point
les migrants risquent leur vie chaque
fois qu'ils viennent ici pour se rendre
en face
en europe et si jean françois bélanger
radio canada asos en sortie